okay thanks uh i want to begin by
thanking the organizers especially amit
hugo
tall guy and shafi for allowing me to be
here this talk will be about a research
area whose central goal
is a deployable system or deployable
systems for verifiable computation were
generally probabilistic proofs
arguments snargs snarks etc and my goal
in this talk
as an applied cs person is to motivate
the next theoretical steps
in this area and i want to do that both
by conveying excitement
and also by applying a bit of a reality
check
okay so the high level setup in this
area is the following we want to arrange
for a client or verifier to send a
description of a computation f
and some input x to a server or approver
who returns the output y
along with the short proof that
establishes for the client that y is the
correct output
given the input x more generally if
f takes non-deterministic input the
proof should establish that the prover
knows a witness that is a setting of the
non-deterministic
input to the validity of the pair xy
the motivation for this setup is the
general lack of trust in third party
computing
as an example we'll see more later but
as an example you can imagine
that a client wants assurance that a
query that's performed on a remote
database was done correctly
now the area has several requirements
beginning with efficiency
which decomposes first of all into the
running time for the verifier
we want it to be constant or logarithmic
in the running time of the computation f
likewise for the communication cost and
the number of rounds that's the ideal
the server's running time should ideally
be linear or quasi-linear in the number
of steps required to execute
f a second requirement is that in some
applications it will be desirable for
the prover's auxiliary input or the
witness w to be private
to the ver from the verifier and
variants of this setup as well as
non-trivial subsets of these properties
have been achievable in
theory including constructions like
interactive proofs
arguments of various kinds zero
knowledge arguments of various kinds and
so forth
but there's an additional requirement
that frames this area and it's that
we want all of this to be practical
and what i mean by practical may not be
what cryptographers mean by practical
but suffice it to say that on the
practicality front there's been good
news
and bad news so the good news is that
there's been a lot of attention to this
area what i'm depicting on the left
is every publication i'm aware of that's
reported on an implementation of a
probabilistic proof protocol
if i have left one out please let me
know i've strived to be comprehensive
so this includes the work of ellie ben
sasson and iran schroemer
alessandro quezada daniel genkin madars
verza it includes the work of babis
papamanthu and elaine she
over here and includes the work of my
group in various places
justin thaler and michael mitzenmacher
and brian parno and craig gentry
as well so the other excitement besides
just the sheer amount of activities that
there's been some genuinely
cool results there have been cost
reductions of 20 orders of magnitude
relative to naive implementations of the
theory
compilers compilers in the sense of an
implementation that go from programs
expressed in a high-level language
to binaries that implement the protocol
entities extensions of the machinery to
broaden expressiveness to computations
that work over remote state and so forth
and most of the systems on the right of
the slide
have verifiers that are genuinely and
concretely efficient
i also cannot resist telling you about
uh
one of the papers done by my group
appeared at sosp which is the premier
operating systems venue
and i think it's fair to say that this
was a landmark for the area or a
milestone at least
but it was also a milestone for sosp
because the system that we sent there
was not remotely practical
now we were very upfront about that but
that brings me to the bad news for this
area and the bad news
is that just because something's
implemented does not mean it's practical
and in fact all of the systems on the
right of the slide here
suffer from the limitation that they
have they can only handle small
computations they have outrageous
expense and so forth so what that means
is that for the time being this
machinery is limited
to carefully selected particular kinds
of applications which i consider to be
bad news given the promise of the area
so that sets up the rest of the talk
i'll describe the state-of-the-art
systems and then also perform a bit of a
reality check and use these things to
motivate what i hope would be the next
theoretical steps in the area since i
think that foundational work is required
okay in summarizing the state of the art
i wish to observe that all of these
systems decompose into a front end and a
back end
the front end takes as input a high
level description of a computation for
example in the c
programming language and outputs an
arithmetic circuit over a large finite
field
the back end is a probabilistic proof
protocol by which the prover can
convince the verifier that there is a
satisfying assignment to that arithmetic
circuit
and it was the job of the front end to
produce the circuit in such a way that
the satisfiability of that circuit
roughly speaking is tantamount to
correct program execution
now the probabilistic proof protocols
that have been refined and implemented
include interactive arguments
non-interactive arguments of various
kinds snarks snarks etc
as well as interactive proofs for lack
of time
i'm unfortunately not going to be able
to describe in detail
the refinements that have been done to
the exciting work of goldwater kalai
and rothblum i'll have to which was done
by
principally justin thaler but i will
restrict focus to arguments and when we
restrict focus to arguments all of the
systems have as one of their central
constructions the quadratic arithmetic
programs
of ggpr gennaro gentry parno and raykova
in order to explain the role of qaps i'm
going to walk through a series of straw
men or
we could say bad ideas for probabilistic
proof protocols
so the first thing you could imagine
doing those of you are graduate students
who've you know taken a complexity
theory class you're like well
uh pcps are pretty awesome they allow us
to check things so what we're going to
do is have the prover materialize the an
asymptotically efficient pcp
send it to the verifier and we know the
pcps of the property but if the
computation was done correctly the
verifier accepts and if the computation
was not done correctly the verifier is
highly unlikely
to accept the proof and the verifiers
work here and checking the proof in the
number of locations where it has to
inspect
is very low the problem with this
picture though is that the approver has
to encode the satisfying assignment in
the proof which means that the proof is
actually larger than the satisfying
assignment
which means that on the basis of
communication and running time at the
verifier
we don't meet the efficiency requirement
from the first slide
so the next thing you can imagine doing
is saying well rather than have the
prover send the proof to the verifier
what we could do is just have the
approver materialize the proof
and then have the verifier ask the
prover what values the proof contains at
particular locations
and this is the paradigm of killian's
arguments and macaulay's computational
soundness proofs
this is actually an excellent idea in
principle
the problem is that the constants that
attend the constructions of short pcps
make this approach very difficult among
other issues
the underlying alphabet here is not a
great fit for the arithmetic circuit
model of computation
iran who'll be speaking next can
probably tell you more about this since
i know that he and ellie ben sasson and
alessandro quiesa
actually implemented this stuff though
they haven't reported on experimental
results so
i i don't know precisely what issues
they ran into but i think this is it
so the next thing you can imagine doing
uh
is to turn to a really cool idea of the
shy kusha levitz and ostrovsky as
a subset of whom are in this room maybe
uh maybe it is uh all of them
and the observation is the following
there's there's really three pieces of
this the first is that in so-called
simple pcps or bad idea pcps
that appear in the first half of the pcp
uh
theorem in the almss paper these these
constructions are actually very simple
they're they're quite straightforward to
implement
the second observation uh is that even
though these proofs
would rely if they were materialized in
full or they would
require the construction of an
exponentially large table
there's actually a much more succinct
representation of such proofs
as a function namely a linear function
function that takes as input a vector
and returns the dot product
of this vector v v here encodes the
satisfying assignment
and the final observation of iko is that
it's possible to get
the prover to commit to a function of
this
form the idea then is that the verifier
asks the prover what values the proof
contains at particular locations
but it's not just that the proof doesn't
have to travel to the verifier
it's also that the approver only has to
compute the locations and the proofs
that are asked for
on demand which means neither party
incurs the exponential blow up
there are so the advantage to this is
that it's simple you could imagine
implementing it my group actually did in
some of the earlier works in this area
the constants are favorable there's two
issues though the first is that because
the proof is exponentially
sized the locations where the verifier
wants to
inspect it for the verifier to
communicate those to the prover
requires itself a very long string which
in turn means that we have to work in a
pre-processing model
where the verifier has to generate these
queries offline and then amortize the
work of doing that
over multiple instances of the same
circuit here
the second disadvantage to this approach
which i'm going to sweep under the rug
for the time being
is that this vector v that you would use
in the naive implementation or
application of this
is actually quadratically larger than
the satisfying assignment and hence the
running time of the computation
but this picture sets up another idea
which is super cool due to botansky
chiesa
ishai ostrovsky and penneth and their
observation is the following
if you're willing to weaken the prover
the cheating prover and assume
that it's restricted to being able to
perform only certain operations in
ciphertext
then it's possible to have that picture
from the previous slide
but in a non-interactive context so this
picture doesn't dispense
with pre-processing but that
pre-processing cost can be incurred once
and then reused over all future
instances of the same computation
rather than over a batch and in this
approach those queries that i mentioned
earlier are actually encrypted
it may not even be the verifier that has
to incur the work to do it there are
variants of this
where a third party can do it iran has
done work on that front
and it's super interesting the provers
responses look very similar to they did
in the other context except they're
happening in cypher space
here so the disadvantage
now to this approach is that besides the
restriction on the prover which
you know may or may not be an issue
depending on your philosophy is that the
provers work required to actually
participate in this protocol is still
quadratic
and i'm going to address that in a
moment but i want to just kind of put
all of these on the same spectrum
and thank raphael pass for kind of
suggesting a figure of this kind
so if you look we started with short
pcps we moved to arguments which
introduced the assumption of collision
resistant hash functions we
then actually made a stronger
cryptographic assumption or iko did and
my own group refined it where we commit
to a longer pcp this introduces the
downside of pre-processing but the key
advantage of simplicity
and plausible constants and then that
same picture
can be realized in a non-interactive way
which gets rid of the issue of
amortizing only over a batch
but we still have the issue that the
provers work is quadratic
i'm going to restrict focus now to these
two approaches because i think these are
kind of
the way things work now so we're going
to exploit the quadratic arithmetic
programs of
or qaps of ggpr and i don't have time to
go into the details of
qaps but what they are is a way of
encoding a circuit
as a set of univariate high degree
polynomials in such a way that if the
circuit's satisfiable
a particular algebraic relationship
holds among the polynomials namely one
polynomial divides another
and that that algebraic relationship can
be checked probabilistically
and furthermore that that probabilistic
check actually has a linear query
structure
up exploiting that fact leads to the
following picture this vector v
that the prover would have otherwise had
to materialize as being quadratic
now becomes just what h here is a
some stuff i'm not going to talk about
that's quasi-linear in z
z is the satisfying assignment to the
circuit so the prover's work now is
shrunk
enormously and this was a critical
development in this research area
i should say though in fairness to ggpr
as well as bciop
the fact that ggpr has a pcp
a linear pcp structure is something that
was not explicit in their paper that
connection was drawn
in work by botansky keyshia stravski and
panetta as well as in
work by my group we expressed this
result in different uh vocabulary but
i think it was fair to say that both
were vigorously expressed
so what this leads to is the following
picture the foundation of all of the
argument back-ends is qaps then the
queries can take place in plain text or
they can take place in the exponent
the back end that implements the
approach on the left my group called
zatar we're systems people so we don't
name things after
our authors names we name you know we
pick other names just to confuse you
and you can think about this as an
interactive argument that refines
the protocol of iko the approach on the
right
is what is now known as a snarg or zero
knowledge snark with pre-processing
ggpr kind of stands at the end of
several other works and it was
implemented
by brian parno craig gentry john howell
and mariana raykova
in a system called pinocchio and then
optimized in a very nice piece
of work and engineering by ben sasonke
as a trumer
and versa in what is a released software
library called libsnark
there's a question that arises when you
see this picture which is can we
dispense with the pre-processing
and it turns out that it's absolutely
possible botansky connetty case and
tromer
uh in in several works from i guess this
dates back to 2011.
um but you can correct me uh iran if i'm
wrong about that show that it's possible
to dispense with pre-processing by
applying this picture recursively
the problem though is that as the
experimental results in some of this
later work
again by subsets of these authors makes
clear these works really should be
considered
theory i mean there are many orders of
magnitude more expensive than the other
approaches
so to just compare the back end on the
left with the back end on the right
effectively the one on the right uses
slightly stronger cryptographic
assumptions
and in return gets much better
cryptographic properties
such as non-interactivity the ability
for the pre-processing work to amortize
indefinitely
and also zero knowledge variants and one
really nice thing which comes out of
ggpr actually
is that the cost of providing zero
knowledge is effectively zero
which is very cool and it has to do with
the details of their construction
so the reason that i'm emphasizing that
all of the systems are based on ggpr
is that even though the systems are
analyzed somewhat differently and they
have different cryptographic protoc
different cryptographic properties the
mechanics are very similar and in fact
are a source of cost and so it's worth
identifying that commonality
okay so now moving to state-of-the-art
front-ends there's this
effectively two different approaches one
approach is to treat
the circuit as the unrolled execution of
a general purpose
processor and to compile a c program to
a binary
in the instruction set of that processor
and then supply that binary is the
input to the arithmetic circuit so this
is a kind of universality
this work was done by uh
again iran and his co-authors elie
benses son alessandro quiesa etc
now the advantage this is extremely
interesting and fascinating uh
the advantage to this is that the
pre-processing work is now incurred only
once for all computations of the same
length
because they're able to reuse that
circuit which is super cool
it's also the case that they have
excellent programmability because having
represented a general purpose cpu
in the circuit they can now handle any
program that compiles to general purpose
cpu
which is all of them the downside is
that the universality has a price
the other approach which uh was done
or is followed by my group as well as
the the pinocchio system due to brian
parno at all as well as
work done by babis papamanthou and
elaine she as well as
the iran's zero cache work which i think
he'll talk about
is to compile c programs to circuits
directly a tailored circuit for the
computation in question
effectively the advantages of and
disadvantages are the inverse of the
ones above
the circuits are much more concise
because the circuit is tailored to the
computation
the amortization is worse because the
pre-processing has to be incurred for
each different circuit in play
and you might think and there is a
question here this this subset of c
sorry this c program in all of the
systems
in this part of the picture is
a subset of c and so that raises the
question how restrictive is the subset
of c and i'll answer that question
in the context of depicting a landscape
of the front ends
so what you have here is most of the
front ends that appear in the literature
and there's a trade-off between
programmability and cost so up and to
the right
is more programmability in terms of
expressiveness that the machinery can
handle
and lower cost and the asic approaches
the ones that are like asics are up here
the ones that are like cpus are down
here
at this point there's a question the
approaches over here
are not good at handling dynamic
loops where loop bounds are become known
only at runtime there are other issues
as well they have problems with
control flow and so forth whereas the
approaches over here
do not have that restriction but they
carry more cost so the question is is it
possible to get the best of both worlds
and in work that we call buffet done in
my group we find that in fact
is possible to get the best of both
worlds buffet has almost the same
expressiveness
as the cpu-based approaches the
limitation being that the subset of c
that it accepts does not handle function
pointers
um and it has excellent or excellent by
comparison costs ideally
some of you could do work that would
push this frontier up and to the right
further okay so this is the common
framework we have back ends based on
qaps different approaches to the front
end
and i now want to perform a little bit
of a reality check and
yeah question about the programmability
the
the two-dimensional picture so
i mean how important is it
to develop cryptographic protocols that
satisfy
uh you know more expressive language
that handle a more expressive language
versus
sort of handling that work at a kind of
a compiler level
and asking a compiler to pre-compile you
know your favorite program into
so this is for example when you compile
to
your compiler to remove function
pointers uh
does that does that is that just like an
insane blow up and complexity
okay so i can't quite tell whether you
could be asking two things maybe more
but the two things you could be asking
are for willing to restrict the front
end does that allow us to employ cheaper
back ends
or you could be asking if we're
restricting the class
of program constructs does that mean
that the circuit that's generated in the
asic model is going to be too large
you could be asking about either yeah i
was i was asking like
how much of the concern over
expressiveness could be handled by
having a you know better com compilers
that
some i'll talk about that later so
um the answer okay so your question i
think is how can we come up with
if we're willing to restrict the front
programmability can we still can we then
come up with more efficient circuits or
conversely if we want to expand
expressiveness can we have concise
circuits for those things
i think that's your question but if not
maybe you can ask me later because i'd
like to
okay
all right so as a reality check i'm
going to do a quick performance study
the we're going to standardize on the
back end the back end is going to be the
lib snark
of iran's group bc tvs optimized
implementation of pinocchio
the front end will be my group's
implementations or re-implementations of
two of the asic based approaches and
then the best
cpu-based approach again due to
bensesson case of trommer and virsup
to put this in context for the landscape
i'm going to be comparing the three
shaded
systems zatar buffet and bctv and to do
apples to apples comparisons we'll run
them on the same computations in the
same
hardware now there's four questions that
arise the first two are what are the
approver's costs and what are the
verifiers costs and i'll answer that
with a model based on micro benchmarks
the things to notice about this model
first of all is that the proof length is
actually quite small
and the per instance cost for the
verifier to check things
is that check computations is pretty low
not as low as we'd like but it's still
pretty low
but there's something else to note about
this model which is that the remainder
of the performance picture
uh the pre-processing cost for the
verifier and the for instance
uh work for the prover actually scales
with the size of the circuit
meaning the number of gates now that
raises two further questions the size of
the circuit is given by the front end so
this raises the question how do the
front ends compare to each other and
also
you know we've got constants in here
like 180 microseconds
60 microseconds is that good or bad i
don't know so let's actually do a quick
uh comparison what this graph is showing
is for three different computations
matrix multiplication merge sort
whatever
uh newth mars pro string search
uh the performance of the front ends
normalized to the best of them which is
buffet
and you know when my group produced this
graph we're like oh this is awesome
buffet's better
than the other front ends by like two
orders of magnitude
we're like patting ourselves on the back
this is fantastic
the thing is a little bit of perspective
is an order because if we compare all of
them
to native execution like we're all
terrible right i mean what this says is
like yeah we're better by one to two
orders of magnitude but basically like
it's because we're all terrible
but actually it's even worse than that
because i'm not even depicting actual
data
this is extrapolated because not all of
the systems can even run
at the input sizes that
we're purporting to depict so what's
depicted on this slide are the actual
input sizes that the various systems can
handle
and as you can see it's kind of the
input sizes are not as large as we would
like
for these various systems the bottleneck
you might be wondering about
is in two places primarily memory
at the prover and also in the verifiers
pre-processing stage
because there's at a certain point
there's a large operation that has to be
performed that's bottlenecked by memory
that means that we can't really handle
computations that take more than 10
million
gates the pre-processing costs are also
extremely high if you want to think
about plausible applications
so some of these issues can be addressed
uh in theory
but the concrete costs are high so just
to summarize the concrete performance
the front end the cpu-based approaches
are better in theory but more expensive
in practice the verifiers variable costs
are genuinely inexpensive the provers
overheads
are scary and memory is
a scaling limit you might wonder well
what about proof carrying data work
this recently appeared at uh eurocrypt
this work actually deals with the
provers memory bottleneck
in principle uh and asymptotically but
the concrete costs make it very
difficult to imagine actually deploying
this anytime
soon gkr drive systems that was the
interactive proof i mentioned
actually better performance for the
verifier the problem is that they're
limited in expressiveness
okay so where do we go from here well
one option would be to
target domains where the provers cost is
tolerable one of those would be the zero
cash system that iran
i think will talk about there it's
actually we don't care if the provers
work is too high because the whole point
of bitcoin is to make people spend cpu
cycles
another application which is detailed in
our work at sosp
is an application of the machinery to
location privacy and for lack of time i
won't have time
for lack of time i won't dive into it
but i'll just point you to our paper
which describes this as an application
where you could imagine actually paying
these costs because effectively
the size of the data in question is
generated on human
scales and so it's not very large
another option which is what i want to
do with the remainder of my time is try
to motivate theoretical advances in this
area
so what do we need well at a high level
we would ideally like to have
three orders of magnitude reduction in
the approver's cost and
the verifiers set up costs ideally we'd
be able to handle inexpensively
interactions with the outside world
right real programs interact with
operating systems files
i o devices etc right now there's not a
concretely efficient way to incorporate
those interactions into the machinery
and ideally in some contexts there will
be some organizations that would prefer
to base the machinery on standard
assumptions this is again ideally
things that could be viewed as a luxury
or non-interactivity depending on the
application obviously for some
applications non-interactivity is
absolutely critical but there are many
other applications like the tooling one
where it's okay if you have
interactivity
it's also the case that pre-processing
while it would be nice to get rid of it
i'd deal with it
as long as the costs aren't too high and
for that matter i don't even necessarily
care
if the proof is of constant length i
tolerate larger proofs
and i tolerate a verifier that could
work harder if we could get the concrete
cost down
so in terms of a wish list for
theoretical advances one
interesting thing would be if you
remember the front end back end
decomposition the front end is producing
arithmetic circuits and the back end is
establishing the satisfiability of those
could we develop probabilistic proof
protocols that are targeted to different
problems besides circuit satisfiability
that have wide applicability this
requires identifying good
candidate problems as well as
identifying probabilistic proof
protocols for those problems
a variant of this would be to take the
general circuit satisfiability
verification machinery but incorporate
or compose
with it special purpose algorithms that
outsource
common pieces of or or i should say
pieces of computations that are
that appear commonly like for example
cryptographic operations
and you know babis and elaine have done
work in that area another thing which
may get to the question you had asked
adam
is about more efficient reductions from
programs to circus this is absolutely of
interest for the most part this is in
the domain of programming languages but
it's i mean i'd be thrilled if people
here want to take this on
a second set of nice to haves would be
concerning the back end so first of all
can we the short pcp paradigm where the
verifier
gets a commitment to a short pcp from
the approver
that was a great idea in principle can
we get short pcps
that are efficient and simple i'm not
the one to do that
some of you are not me it would be great
if that existed
another thing would be to endow iko's
arguments those
the interactive arguments with
pre-processing with better properties so
i i don't know if these are covered by
impossibility results i hope not but it
would be cool if we could reuse
this is something i talked about with
daniel wicks a while ago could we and
abhishel out could we reuse
they did the talking i did the listening
could we reuse the processing
work over more than a batch indefinitely
that would be ideal could we make the
protocol zero knowledge
could we make stronger assumptions and
or
improve the analysis because some of the
costs in this protocol
come out of the way that soundness is
established
another thing although the disclaimer is
that qaps and ggpr
have come very far but they are a
principal source of cost still so is it
possible to improve them
or to improve the cryptography that's
sitting on top of qaps
and finally what would be cool if you
imagine imagine that the cloud has
special purpose processors that are
really good at handling cryptographic
operations
well i'm telling you that cryptographic
operations are one of the key
bottlenecks in these systems
so could we get to the point where the
cryptographic operations could
themselves be outsourced
and then the verifier would check that
those cryptographic operations were done
correctly
so there's a lot of other ideas needed
of course even if we make progress on
all of those it's not going to make
this stuff plausibly deployable tomorrow
but we don't all know what they are i'd
be thrilled if i could motivate
the graduate students in this room to
think about this area and work on these
problems
so to just quickly wrap up i've tried to
say or communicate that this is an
exciting area
that has both good news and bad news the
bad news is that implementation does not
imply
deployability the overhead really comes
from two places the overhead
of transforming programs into circuits
and the overhead
of the qap backend and the cryptography
layered on top of it
i believe we need theoretical
breakthroughs and
that's going to be a lot of work it's a
high bar but as incentive i think the
potential here is very large
if we had low overhead ways of verifying
computation the results
would have wide applicability i believe
so i'll stop there and take questions if
there's time
so while the next speaker sets up maybe
a question
note that we will have a full hour
discussion on
all these topics in the afternoon so we
can have more extensive discussions then
um so my question is uh do you have a
sense of
uh which of the overheads is bigger or
the order of magnitude on them so for
example if you stripped all the
cryptography out and just did the pcp
but sort of assumed
answering the questions i know it
doesn't make sense but what would be the
cause of that is the cross-country just
answering these pc
queries or doing it in a cryptographic
way
that's a really good question it comes
from two places so if we just strip the
cryptography out of it the provers still
and this cost can be addressed in theory
using their stuff um
the prover still has to do a fairly
large
operation on the entire just qap's
mandate
that the prover does polynomial
arithmetic and finite
fast free transforms on uh the
satisfying assignment
that's a bottleneck that would exist
independent of the cryptography
having said that if you could get rid of
the cryptography you just have qaps
no um no crypto on top of it the cost
would go down they go down i mean i'm
i'm making this up but my sense is like
two orders of magnitude right there
so in running time but not the memory
bottleneck to be clear
you mentioned um problems that come up
um a lot that you would say if we had a
special solution
like an adoption mission that would
require the general purpose machinery
that then you could sort of plug it in
in the and sort of reduce the hover head
what would be an example of that
like right so i mean to some extent we
need to identify these right there are
lots of computations i care about
um you know like the things that i use
computers for every day
the question is what you know what is
the commonality what can be extracted
such that we could have a good
probabilistic
cruise system i actually don't know it's
something i definitely want to think
about
um and one of the things i'd like to
talk to people about but
i mean certainly if there were
operations that could allow for
transformations on for example databases
which if you think about or data
structures that are you know stored
right this is a rolling of the circuit
the program into a circuit
are there structures in the resulting
circuit that somehow
uh seem to take a lot of time or a lot
of uh
or they'll repeat themselves a lot i see
what you're asking okay
excellent question so the question is
what types i think of higher level
program constructs
translate into expense in the circuit
representation
and yeah so i'm actually not sure i mean
one of the things that tends to blow up
which is kind of a bummer
is that in the asic based approaches
time and conditionality turn into space
so if you have an if statement or a
switch statement with four different
possibilities
the circuit now needs logic for each of
those four possibilities
that's a bummer another thing that's
more expensive than we'd like is
it sounds crazy but inequality
comparisons if the computation needs to
check that one number's less than
another
it turns out that that introduces
expense for
um reasons i could go into but i think
i'm out of time let's thank speaker
again